einstein travaillait sur sa théorie de
la gravité tous les scientifiques de son
temps avait une fois indélébile en la
mécanique newtonienne d'ailleurs
lorsqu'une anomalie dans la trajectoire
d'uranus fut détectée les théoriciens
suivirent aveuglément les pas de newton
est plutôt que de renoncer à sa théorie
préférèrent expliqué l'anomalie d'uranus
par l'existence d'une huitième planètes
dans le système solaire
aussi fou que cela puisse paraître comme
nous en avons déjà parlé dans l'épisode
2 il avait raison et neptune fut alors
découverte du coup quand on découvrit
que la trajectoire de mercure n'était
pas tout à fait une ellipse personne ne
doutait de la théorie newtonienne urbain
le verrier qu'elle ait prédit
l'existence de neptune avec succès
préféra expliqué l'anomalie de mercure
par l'existence d'une neuvième planète
du système solaire entre mercure et le
soleil qui l'appela vulcain cependant le
jeune et audacieux einstein osent
imposer la question que personne n'avait
osé poser et si cette anomalie n'était
pas causé par une neuvième planète du
système solaire
et si cette anomalie n'était rien
d'autre qu'une preuve que la théorie de
newton n'était qu'une approximation un
développement limité d'une théorie de la
gravité plus fondamentale en 1912
albert einstein se rendit à zurich pour
retrouver son ancien professeur de
mathématiques marcel crossman et partir
à la quête d'une équation à travers
laquelle la matière d'ict à l'espace
temps sa courbure assez vite
grossman propose à einstein une équation
mais à la fois grossman et engine finir
pas la rejeter
elle ne semblait pas être à même de
prédire les trajectoires que newton
avait déjà prédit
au lieu d'insister sur cette équation
einstein fabrique à sa propre équation
toutefois submergé par la monstruosité
des équations en jeu einstein et choix
dans son calcul de la trajectoire de
mercure mais comme leur théorie n'est
fait de très belle manière la relativité
restreinte et le principe d'équivalence
installé grossman était en fait assez
contents de leur théorie il l'a publié
donc en 1913 et demandèrent aux
expérimentateurs de la tester en partant
en quête des clips solaire la théorie
que la gravité de newton s'applique des
objets ayant une masse et ne s'applique
donc pas à la lumière car la lumière n'a
pas de masse cependant dans la
relativité d'einstein la gravité courbe
l'espace-temps
et cette courbure des formes l'espace à
travers le temps or la lumière se
déplace à travers l'espace donc cette
déformation de l'espace affecte la
trajectoire de la lumière
c'est ainsi que la trajectoire de la
lumière nous paraît courbet depuis la
terre en particulier lorsque l'on
observe une éclipse solaire imposition
des étoiles derrière le soleil doit
différer de celles dans le ciel la nuit
et c'est cette déviation qui devait être
la confirmation de la théorie d'einstein
cependant les éclipses sont rares elles
ne se réalise qu'à des lieux et des
moments très spécifique mais surtout la
première guerre mondiale ont envahi
toute l'europe
puis le monde ceux-ci ralenti
drastiquement l'avancé des expéditions
qui cherchait à confirmer ou réfuter la
théorie d'einstein et de grossman se
font une très grosse déception pour
einstein
à moins que
de façon ironique ses échecs des
sciences expérimentales fut un miracle
pour un carrière d'einstein
en effet en 1915 alors que les
expérimentateurs était encore dans
l'incapacité d'effectuer leurs
observations
einstein découvrit que ces calculs
étaient faux pris de panique reste
chercher à réparer sa théorie pendant ce
temps le plus grands mathématiciens de
l'époque nous pendait à vide
gilbert parti à la poursuite d'einstein
en se lançant à son tour à la quête de
l'équation temps sur elle qui pourrait
expliquer la trajectoire de mercure
qu'elle envoie ce fut pour einstein
il travailla dur très très dur mais il
resté coincé à court d'idées sa propre
théorie de la gravité semblait entendue
lui file entre les doigts
à plusieurs reprises cru d'avoir tous
résolus mais il finit encore et encore
par trouver des erreurs dans ses calculs
et à tout moment il peut risquer de le
crier sur la ligne d'arrivée dans un
acte de désespoir il reprit l'équation
que lui avait proposée grossman compris
que les arguments qu'il avait avancée
pour la rejeter était infondée et l'âme
audi kolles légèrement pour garantir la
conservation de l'énergie contemple à
cette équation
et puis saisi par son incroyable beauté
sa surprenante élégance cette équation
avait tout pour plaire
il était alors temps de les faire passer
le test final cette équation elles et
elles permettent de prédire la bonne
trajectoire de mercure pour répondre à
cette question capitale
einstein se lança dans des calculs
laborieux
ici les interminables passe à des jours
et des nuits à calculer calculer et
calculé encore et encore et encore et
encore et encore et encore et encore
tout
il trouva la bonne réponse après des
pages de kaluza frais dit il
einstein avait déduit la trajectoire de
mercure de ces équations enfin avait-il
dans ses mains théorie qui prédit vieux
les trajectoires des planètes que notait
la théorie de newton et avait raison il
avait triomphé dans les jours qui
suivirent lui de dangereuses
palpitations cardiaques dus à son
excitation extrême il écrivit les années
de recherche angoissante dans
l'obscurité avec leur alternance intense
et interminable d'instants de confiance
de moments de fatigue et l'émergence
finale dans la lumière
seuls ceux qui l'ont vécue peuvent même
si je n'ai jamais rien découvert qu'ils
soient ne serait ce qu un iota de ce
qu'a découvert einstein
cette citation résonne beaucoup avec moi
quand je fais des mathématiques quand je
cherche à prouver des nouveautés au ram
ou corps essaie d'apprendre des théories
bien établis comme la relativité
générale d'einstein
la plupart du temps je suis complètement
perdue 99% du temps je ne comprends
juste rien à ce qui se passe
et puis parfois après beaucoup de
travail et de façon souvent inattendues
une connexion se fait dans mon cerveau
est là et là c'est juste génial c'est
juste l'extase et tout beaucoup de tours
en d'idées qui traverse mon esprit et
tant de choses s'éclaircissent d'un coup
d'un seul lien je dirais que l'un des
plus gros problèmes avec l'éducation
surtout en maths
aujourd'hui c'est que la quasi totalité
des étudiants n'ont jamais vécu ce
moment fantastique
des années plus tard en 1919 ce
redington confirma la théorie d'einstein
à l'aide de l'observation d'une éclipse
étrangement einstein le prix quasiment
pour une anecdote
l'anomalie de merkel avait déjà
convaincu de la validité de sa théorie
mais pour le reste de l'inter c'était la
plus belle nouvelle qu'ils avaient
entendu depuis bien longtemps alors
qu'il faisait encore le deuil des
victimes de la première guerre mondiale
les médias et le grand public à travers
le monde
trouvèrent enfin une raison de sourire
alors qu'ils célébraient la chute des
vieilles idées de newton et l'avènement
de la nouvelle théorie révolutionnaire
de l'espace du temps et de la gravité
par einstein
c'est à l'issue de cette excitation
unique dans l'histoire des sciences
qu'une nouvelle génération de physiciens
émergea et développa une théorie
antagonistes pour les échelle
microscopique la théorie de la mécanique
quantique ça depuis la théorie de la
relativité générale n'a cessé d'être
confirmé gravity propre pays a montré qu
une toupie en orbite tourner exactement
comme l'aurait prédit einstein tandis
que des rayons laser envoyé depuis le
bas jusqu'en haut d'une tour ont
confirmé la dilatation gravitationnelles
dues tant prédite par einstein et puis
plus récemment encore il y eut la
détection des ondes gravitationnelles
comme on parle florence porcel est avide
aux âpres du coût de nos jours on a une
confiance tels en la théorie d'einstein
qu'on l'utilisent pour localiser les
amas de galaxies en mesurant leur effet
de lentille gravitationnelle est pour
nous localiser à la surface de la terre
à l'aide de la technologie gps mais au
cours des dernières décennies
deux observations cosmologique montre
que la théorie d'einstein ne colle en
fait pas avec la réalité
d'un côté les galaxies tournent plus
vite que ce que l'on croyait alors que
les galaxies
stomp s'éloigne de nous en accélérant
ceci montre qu'elle est celle des
galaxies qu à courbure de l'espace temps
est plus grande que ce qu'einstein avait
prédit mais qu'à l'échelle
intergalactique la courbure de l'espace
temps se fait dans la direction opposée
à ce que disent les équations d'einstein
est ce que ceci prouve qu'un la navette
or bien comme il ya son temps on a une
confiance tels en la théorie dominante
de la physique de la gravité que plutôt
que de rejeter la théorie d'einstein
on préfère expliquer ces anomalies par
l'existence d'objets non observé à
l'échelle des galaxies on appelle ça la
matière noire qui ajouterait à l'effet
gravitationnel des galaxies et à
l'échelle intergalactique
on parle d'énergie noire qui
contrôlerait les effets classiques de la
gravité à très très très grande jeune
mais matière noire énergie noire ne sont
que des mots qu'on a inventé pour
l'occasion on ne sait absolument pas de
quoi il s'agit
tout ce que l'on sait c'est que si la
matière noire et l'énergie noire sont
bien là alors la théorie d'einstein est
à nouveau parfaitement cohérente avec
les observations cependant ne peut pas
exclure la possibilité que l'histoire
est en fait en train de se répéter et
que ses anomalies à très grande échelle
sont en fait des preuves que la théorie
d'einstein n'est qu'une approximation
d'une théorie encore plus fondamentale
que celle qu einstein avait découverte
la dernière fois j'avais essayé
d'apporter pas mal de clarification à la
théorie de la relativité générale tels
que j'avais présenté dans les deux
projets pilotes qui venaient encore
avant lui limete à demande du coup
qu'ils avaient raison newton ou einstein
ben j'espère vous avoir montré dans cet
épisode que les observations montrent
que einstein avait raison et non pas
newton puisqu'il ya des prédictions que
font la théorie de newton qui ont été
réfutées comme le fait que la lumière
n'est pas dévié de sa trajectoire par la
gravité je rajouterais que je trouve que
la théorie d'einstein bas aussi celle de
newton d'un point de vue théorique
alors ça c'est subjectif de savoir
laquelle de ces deux théories est la
plus belle mais le truc assez étrange
dans la théorie de newton dont j'ai
parlé dans l'épisode 17 c'est le fait
que la masse initiale devait égal à la
masse gravitationnelle du coup il y
avait une espèce de coïncidences
cosmique qui rend la théorie de newton
pas belle la théorie d'einstein
elle ne fait pas cette hypothèse
puisqu'il n'ya pas de masse
gravitationnelle en théorie de la
relativité générale et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je pense que la
théorie d'einstein bas à celle de newton
d'un point de vue théorique également
c'est une des raisons qui expliquent
pourquoi einstein était si convaincu par
sa théorie bien avant que des résultats
expérimentaux de la confiance médias
nucléaire s'étonne que je n'utilise pas
le terme géodésique elle que je parle
constamment de ligne droite dans des
espaces cours c'est vraiment un choix
éditorial je pense que utilisait mot
géodésique peut faire fuir des gens
donner l'impression qu'on est qu on fait
des trucs plus compliqué que ça ne l'est
vraiment et d'un autre côté je trouve
que le mot ligne droite les espèces
corvette un mot qui convient
parfaitement
parce qu'il correspond exactement à
cette intuition derrière ligne droite
que l'on pourrait avoir c'est à dire une
droite
c'est ce que l'on obtient lorsque l'on
va tout droit et ça se fait ni droite
que reçoit nos espaces cour ou dans des
espaces plats victor allèles et l'arche
me demander de refaire le point un petit
peu sur les forces de la nature donc les
forces de la nature il y a techniquement
la force de la gravité d'un côté et la
force électromagnétique la force
nucléaire faible et la force nucléaire
forte de l'autre côté la force nucléaire
forces à celles qui permet de former des
noyaux dans quelques décharges positive
mais elle arrive quand même à rester
ensemble
la force nucléaire faible responsable
entre autres de la radioactivité
et en gros tout le reste dans notre vie
quotidienne est expliquée par
l'électromagnétisme leur litre au
magnétisme a été un peu formalisés pour
la première fois par les équations de
maxwell au 19ème siècle mais elle a été
complètement repensé ensuite au cours du
20e siècle par des gens comme d'irak ou
par feynman au plus tard qu'ils ont fait
une théorie quantique de
l'électromagnétisme que l'on appelle
parfois l'électrodynamique quantique
ukyou il dit ces initiales anglaises
l'une des prédictions de
l'électrodynamique quantique qui n'a pas
tellement à voir etc les traumatismes en
tant que tel mais plutôt avec les
fondements de la mécanique quantique
c'est le fait que la matière ne veut pas
être réduite en un point particulier on
ne peut pas mettre deux électrons dans
le même état quantique c'est ce qu'on
appelle le principe de paoli et si on
veut être assez grossier on peut dire
que ce principe de paoli qui empêche les
électrons d'être dans le même état
quantique est la raison pour laquelle la
matière ne veut pas se retrouver tous en
même endroit et qu'elle attend ce plutôt
à se repousser
lors du coup on a trois forces d'un côté
qui sont décrits par la mécanique
quantique est une force de côté qui est
décrite par la relativité générale et ça
ça m'amène à la question de malik
soumaré qui se pose la question de
savoir qu'est ce qui rompt l'unification
de toutes ses forces si difficile avant
de commencer je précise que quand on
parle de gravité quantique nous gravité
correspond à la courbure de l'espace
temps et non pas à l'accélération des
référentiels donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a du mal à avoir une théorie quantique
de la courbure de l'espace temps
c'est une question qui me dépassent
largement et je ne maîtrise absolument
pas cette question
mais bon je peux quand même faire le
perroquet qui a fait ce que des experts
disent on sait comment quantifier des
courbure de l'espace temps pour les
rendre aux cantiques donc faudra des
déformations de l'espace temps qui
serait quantifier du coup cette
quantification de cette déformation de
l'espace temps serait ce qu'on appelle
un gravitons mais apparemment lorsqu'on
essaie de
dérouler les équations on tombe sur
plainte d'un fini il ya des trucs qui
marchent au pas la jeune future est et
est ce que l'on dit et du coup il faut
être un petit peu plus malin que
simplement quantifier directement
l'équation d'einstein pour pouvoir avoir
une théorie quantique de la gravité pour
ce faire il ya deux grands prétendants à
y arriver
la théorie des cordes d'un côté qui a
l'air vachement compliqué qui est le
principal prétendant à une théorie du
tout et dont david au havre a parlé dans
un épisode assez étonnante et de l'autre
côté on a la théorie de la gravité
quantique à boucles et david a annoncé
qu'il allait un jour a expliqué cette
corrida gravité quantique tiago moi
j'attends impatiemment cet épisode parce
que je n'y connais rien aux patients de
voir ce qu'ils vont venir
je vous rappelle que le défilé 3 est en
cours le défilé le suivant une à deux
étoiles qui tourne l'une autour de
l'autre une des étoiles explose que se
passe-t-il si vous voulez proposer votre
réponse mettez la dans les commentaires
du défilé deux sinon je risque de louper
votre commentaire une grosse partie de
ce problème consiste simplement à savoir
quelle est la bonne question qu'il faut
se poser quand je dis que ce pastis une
question vaille mais c'est la question
qui m'a été posée parce qu'on attendait
de moi que je me pose la bonne question
à poser
y en a pas mal par mais vous qui m'ont
dit à peut-être qu'il va se passer si ou
ça et en effet il peut se passer
plusieurs choses mais du coup la
question qui vient juste après c'est
notamment de savoir de quoi ça va
dépendre
pourquoi est-ce que ça passe et si
plutôt que ça et comment on peut le
prédire quel va être le calcul à faire
donc j'attends pas forcément tout le
raisonnement tous les calculs qui vont
avec juste des idées du raisonnement
global je serais très content mais
n'hésitez pas à faire ses calculs la si
vous savez les faire c'est un très bon
exercice surtout si vous êtes en prit
peur est là j'espère que vous avez aimé
cet épisode la prochaine fois on va
appliquer la théorie d'einstein au
cosmos et on va faire de la cosmologie
en relativité générale et étudier
notamment qu'elles sont
les fins possibles du monde si vous avez
aimé c'est l'épisode penser à le zinc et
à le commenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner à cette chaîne
pour ne pas manquer les futurs épisodes
et j'espère que je verrai la prochaine
fois ci que le laboratoire en chute
libre se comporte comme un référentiel
inertielle c'est parce qu'il est
fondamentalement et qui va nous il se
rappelle qu'il a eu un professeur qui
s'appelle marcel grossman qui était un
spécialiste des justement des géométrie
non euclidienne